bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 24 septembre 2014 du journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 il est 18h si vous
nous suivez en direct et dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui le Secours
populaire français poursuit sa campagne
pauvreté précarité 2014 après la
publication d'un rapport et du enquiète
sur la situation en France il vient de
recevoir les premières livraisons
alimentaires du Fond européen d'aide au
plus démuni vous le verrez dans un
instant la Journée européenne des
langues qui se prépare dans 48 he la
diversité linguistique sera à l'honneur
l'apprentissage aussi invité Frédéric
Seb directeur du centre de ressources et
espace Langle serel de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline dans
les Yvelines l'histoire locale ce sont
aussi ses ferme qui la raconte elle
traverse les siècles et se visite comme
celle de champ-garnier à Saint-Lambert
des bois retour sur l'un des événements
qui a marqué cette 31e journée du
patrimoine ce weekend un homme de 26 ans
blessé par balle hier soir mardi attrape
il se trouve à l'hôpital de la commune
avec une plaie à l'abdomen la
conséquence d'une risque qui a éclaté un
peu plusut tôt aux alentours de 18h dans
un quartier de la ville le SIR allé au
larange théâtre d'affrontement entre une
quarantaine de jeunes la police est
intervenue pour les disperser avant de
nouveau les échafouré à
22h50 très précisément avant que la
police n'intervienne une nouvelle fois
et ne découvre sur place couteau bomb
acrymogène ou encore barre de fer une
enquête pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire est en cours une
interpellation a déjà eu lieu invité de
ce journal Frédéric Seb bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur du centre de
ressources et espace langue le CRL de
l'Université de Versailles saquentin en
Yveline journée européenne des langues
le 26 septembre vous allez proposer des
portes ouvertes à cette occasion comme
ça le grand public pourra découvrir vos
activités le serel bien que dépendant de
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
on va tout de suite le préciser ne
s'adresse pas uniquement aux étudiants
absolument vous êtes ouvert aux
entreprises au particuliers qui au
particuliers aux extérieurs aux
demandeurs d'emploi et cetera nous avons
une partie de notre public qui est
étudiant et des particuliers qui
interviennent nous formons également
pour les personnels UVSQ et comme nous
assurons des certifications bien
évidemment nous avons des gens qui
viennent soit des stages de formation
pour passer les certifications ou qui
les passent tout simplement pour les
obtenir on va parler des méthodes de
travail on va voir comment vous
travaillez avec le CRL mais tout d'abord
sur cette journée des langues étrangères
cette journée européenne qui existe
depuis 2001 son son objectif c'est quoi
qu'il faut apprendre des des langues et
que c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui alors
qu'il faut oui mais en tout cas c'est de
promouvoir l'enseignement des langues la
pratique des langues faire baisser les
barrières parce que effectivement le
l'enseignement des langues est un
enseignement tout à fait particulier
très difficile et parfois très
perturbateur donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
essayer de développer dans un ensemble
la Communauté européenne qui dispose de
nombreuses
deso les capacités tout simplement à se
comprendre est-ce que les Français sont
des bons élèves en général non c'est ce
quiessort des différenteses nous avons
la réputation d'être mauvais en langue
c'est un prof de langue professeur
d'espagnol qui vous le dit donc c'est
très embêtant mais bon nous avons la
réputation d'tre mauvais en langue et ça
s'explique comment vous qui les avez ces
étudiants que ce soit plus qui viennent
des particuliers des étudiants donc on
disait alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je dise que mes étudiants sont
mauvais il nit pas question mes
étudiants sont très bons en langue et
très bon en espagnol puis mais qu'est-ce
qu' les freine en tout cas lorsqu'ils
arrivent les difficultés qu'il
rencontrent je je pense que
l'apprentissage se fait un petit peu
tard et pour avoir été enseignant en
collège et enseigné également en
primaire ce n'est pas systématisé et
c'est systématisé un petit peu tard
d'autre part le l'apprentissage et
langue se faisant sur des jours sur des
he un petit peu varié pas très souvent
ça ne facilite pas les choses il y a pas
assez d'efforts et en tout cas c'est pas
fait assez tôt suffisamment tôt à
l'école peut-être pas suffisamment tô
après bon les efforts sont particul
peut-être qu'on devrait prendre
conscience du fait que un enseignement
de langue n'est pas dans un enseignement
d'une autre matière on peut mettre 30 ou
35 élèves dans une classeune matière
normale pour la pratique de l'oral 30
c'est très difficilement gérable il faut
bien le reconnaître donc il y a encore
des efforts à faire de ce côté-là du
côté de UC nationale absolument même si
évidemment chacun fait ce qu'il peut et
chaque enseignant défend sa matière donc
automatiquement je suis là pour défendre
la mienne quelles sont les langues
étrangères que vous maîtrisez c'est la
question que nous sommes allés vous
poser aujourd'hui à Saint-Quentin en
evveline vos réponses l'anglais parce
que ça fait plusieurs années que j'en
fais et a l'espagnol donc j'aime bien
donc forcément je maîtrise aussi chinois
français anglais chinois c'est ma langue
maternelle et puis l'anglais c'est ma
première langue étrangère et français
c'est la deuxème comme langue je
maîtrise un peu l'anglais quelques
notion d'allemanditalien mais c'est tout
espagnol parce que l'Espagne c'est un
pays que j'aime beaucoup et c'est très
apprécié par tout le monde d'ailleurs et
puis voilà c'est une langue qui est très
intéressante c'est B latine et j'aime
beaucoup c'est plus facile que
l'anglais l'anglais le japonais
l'espagnol le français bien sûr ma
langue maternelle et j'ai des notions de
rus
aussi qu'on dit une JEE pour lui dire
qu'elle est jolie St dire bonjour CDA
comment ça va donc un élève modèle
doublé d'un dragueur on l'a bien compris
pour le dernier téléspectateur en tout
cas ce qu'on entend le plus souvent
c'est l'anglais l'espagnol ça veut dire
qu'on s'intéresse peu aux autres langues
c'est ce qu'on vous demande quand on
vient au CRL alors les langues
enseignées au SERL c'est essentiellement
anglais espagnol et le fleu le français
langue étrangère ceci dit nous en nous
avons la possibilité de proposer une
dizaine de langues au total mais c'est
vrai que l'anglais espagnol sont les
plus importantes largement au-dessus
pour l'anglais l'anglais pour des
raisons évidentes de commerce
international d'échang l'espagnol parce
que effectivement en nombre de de de
parlant de d'hispanophone le chiffre est
considérable et c'est parlé dans une
vingtaine de pays ce qui fait l'attrait
d'une langue c'est aussi
l'internationalisme au niveau de
plusieurs continent que ce soit le
japonais que ce soit le chinois est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui est demandé
aussi alors le chinois est vraiment en
développement de ce point de le japonais
oui on mais surtout le chinois on
commence à voir poindre un peu le russe
mais à notre niveau peut-être pas trop
trop on parle de cette journée des
langues étrangères qui se déroulera le
26 septembre avec le serel le Centre
d'études de l'Université de versaill
Saint-Quentin en Yveline comment va se
dérouler votre participation il y aura
des portes ouvertes dans les trois
antennes Versailles monte et aiguille en
cours absolument effectivement
l'université de versaill Saint-Quentin
est une est sur plusieurs sites donc
nous aussi nous avons un serel àuté de
manth un sur le site de Versailles de la
Faculté des Sciences et ici à guoncour
le principe c'est d'avoir une espèce
déparation portes ouvertes qui nous
permet d'accueillir un petit peu les
gens de présenter notre gamme de
produits de faire une une présentation
un petit peu d'accueillir le plus
possible pour que les gens se sentent
bien c'est surtout ça qui est important
parce que nous avons une équipe
extrêmement mobilisée pour aider pour
faire tomber les barrières alors il y a
des visites des serel il y a des
ateliers gratuits pendant la période ou
des possibilités de de de se servir du
matériel qui est proposé et cetera
l'idée c'est de présenter un petit peu
ce que nous pouvons faire et surtout ce
qu'ils peuvent ce qu'ils peuvent faire
comment se passe l'apprentissage c'est
quelles sont vos méthodes c'est très
individualisé vous disz tout à l'heure
dans une classe 30 35 élèves c'est trop
alors ça dépend ça dépend complètement
c'est vrai que nous avons une gamme de
produits qui est très varié là-dessus à
l'université il y a des enseignements de
langues qui se font dans le cadre des
formations et nous nous intervenons nous
nous intervenons en
complément c'est-à-dire que soit ils
peuvent travailler d'une manière
totalement individuelle en formation à
distance ou en présentiel à leur niveau
et la gamme de produits que nous
proposons nous permet de nous adapter un
petit peu à ce dont ils ont besoin ce
qu'ils cherchent et à leur profil
particulier tout cela coûte cher pour
suivre une formation si on est un
extérieur on est un particulier
qu' franchement nous avons une gamme de
prix très importante et et ça dépend
véritablement de de ce qu'on re cherche
et euh des objectifs qu'on se fixe juste
parce qu'on est sur l'aspect financier
une petite parenthèse hier à votre place
le président de l'université Jean-Luc
vessier était présent pour revenir sur
cette rentrée et évoquer la la crise qui
a traversé l'établissement l'année
dernière il nous a expliqué que les
choses allaient mieux que c'était en
tout cas sur de bonnes sur de bon rail
est-ce que ça a eu un impact sur le CRL
sur vos façon de fonctionner puisque
vous dépendez de l'université écoutez
nous nous sommes adaptés une faculté
d'adoptation et on a on s'est mobilisé
de façon à ce que nos nos nos enfin les
gens qui viennent chez nous ne sentent
pas véritablement cette pression et
voilà on a fait des efforts et puis
comme tout le monde dans l'université
que ce soit au niveau des intervenants
ou au niveau des personnels on va
revenir aux langues étrangères puisque
c'est le cœur de l'entretien ce soir
juste pour vous donner cette information
qui ne vous a peut-être pas échappé en
début de semaine le programme Erasmus
puisqu'on parle des longues étrangères
et le fait de les apprendre le mieux
c'est aussi de se rendre dans le pays
concerné et le programme Erasmus a
contribué à la naissance d'un million de
bébés depuis 1987 voilà entendu ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
ceux qui veulent se rendre à l'étranger
on rencontre facilement son conjoint à
l'étranger plus facilement 50% de ceux
qui ont rencontré qui sont partis à
l'étranger ont rencontré leurs conjoint
comme ça clairement je dois vous dire
que puisque je suis enseignant en
espagnol j'interviens en licence ce
n'est pas le but premier des étudiants
que nous envoyons en éasmus cons c'est
peut-être lesff auberge espagnol mais
peut-être ça effectivement mais bon on
va dire que pour nous véritablement
enseignant c'est quand même secondaire
c'est peut-être pas comme ça que vous le
v c'est sûr vous restez avec nous encore
quelques instants vous allez pouvoir
suivre ce reportage à présent de yolen
Torz réalisé à trappe cet après-midi
toujours dans le cadre de la Journée
européenne des langues professionnels
parents enfants qui se sont retrouvés
autour de la transmission des langues
dans la famille à
l'école cette jeune fille est en classe
européenne au collège Gagarine de trappe
accompagnée de sa maman elle est venue
échanger et discuter sur les langues
étrangères apprise à l'école et en
famille un débat proposé par la maison
des parents dans le cadre des Journées
européennes des langues et donc vous
vous avez envie de les ouvrir quand même
aux langues étrangèr justement par
l'école cette collégienne parle quatre
langues le français est l'arabe à la
maison l'anglais et l'espagnol à l'école
un bel exemple de plurilinguisme que la
maison des parents souhaite mettre en
avant à travers ces rencontre
transmettre l'idée que la diversité
linguistique n'est pas un danger pour
l'équilibre je dirais de vie des uns et
des autres au contraire de chefs
d'établissement scolaires de trappe sont
venus participer à l'action car l'enjeu
est également de voir quelle place est
donné aux langues des familles dans les
écoles sur la ville de trappe environ 75
langues familiales seraient recensées
l'arabe est une des plus représenté
ensuite nous avons aussi le soniqué qui
est très représenté le Poulard
le le
Portugais on a aussi la langue turque la
langue créole le
mandarin la langue
allemande autant de richesses qui seront
au cœur d'un autre débat ce jeudi 25
septembre un débat ouvert à tous de 14h
à 17h à la Maison des
Parents l'apprentissage des langues à
l'école dans un contexte d'éducation
familiale plurilingue c'était le thème
de la réunion qui s'est tenue cet
après-midi votre regard plusieurs
langues parler à la maison en plus de
l'apprentissage à l'école est-ce que
c'est un atout
je pense que c'est un atout je pense
qu'effectivement quand on apprend une
langue on a plus de facilité pour en
apprendre une deuxème voir une trè et C
oui je je ne sais pas trop comment
l'expliquer mais peut-être la la
fluidité la souplesse d'esprit qui fait
que ça facilite les choses ça me semble
une très très bonne chose effectivement
que elle vit dans une société cette
petite jeune fille on a vu au départ qui
est française qui parle dans sa langue
de culture au départ qui est l'arabe et
en même temps elle a un apprentissage
des deux autres langues qui sont
principales dans l'enseignement en
France et puis elle est dans une classe
européenne apparemment ce qui fait qu'
on insiste en particulier pour avoir une
matière qui est enseignée dans une
langue étrangère et cet élément de
classe européenne est une très très
bonne chose enfin tout est bon dans
l'apprentissage des langues et c'est
vrai que l'objectif c'est d'améliorer le
plus possible les choses favoriser la la
diversité encourager l'échange c'est le
but de ces journées de cette journée
européenne des langues qui se déroulera
le 26 merci Frédéric se du centre de
ressources Espace langue de l'Université
de versaill Saint-Quentin on rappelle
que vous participez à cette événement
avec des portes ouvertes de vos antennes
de guuill en cours manth et versaill
merci à vous merci à vous l'actualité de
ce ce 24 septembre c'est aussi le
Secours populaire français qui poursuit
sa campagne pauvreté précarité 2014
après la publication d'un rapport
alarmant où l'on apprenait que pour des
milliers de personnes aidées par
l'organisation il ne restait que 5,60 €
par jour pour manger et s'habiller c'est
maintenant l'antenne ivlinoise qui
conviait la presse à la réception des
premières livraisons du Fond européen
d'aide au plus démunis c'était à trrappe
ce matin le reportage de William
l décharger porter et répartir le camion
du fond d'aide européen vient d'arriver
ce matin les bénévoles du Secours
populaire ont répondu présent pour
réceptionner la première livraison de
l'année destiné aux ivelinois les plus
nécessiteux il y a de plus en plus de
familles qui demandent des aides
alimentaires donc je pense que c'est
normal aussi de faire quelque chose dans
la mesure de mes moyens cette année dans
le département ce sont plus de 2000
familles qui sont accueillies par les
permanences de l'association un chiffre
en constante augmentation ça a beaucoup
augmenté sur l'année dernière dernière
puisqueon était aux environs de 1800 et
là on a dépassé les 2000 donc en une
année on a on a eu une augmentation de
plus de 200 familles ce qui est
relativement important pour une
structure comme la nôtre puisque la
composition moyenne d'un foyer c'est
plus de 4 personnes environ 7000
personnes en situation précaire viennent
frapper à la porte du Secours populaire
l'association a du mal à répondre à la
demande pour un département comme celui
des evelines les les produits de l'Union
européenne représentent entre 40 et 50 %
de ce que l'on repropose une finé aux
gens sous la forme d'un colis
alimentaire le le le fait de travailler
ne protège plus de de de la pauvreté
c'est-à-dire que quand vous êtes au SMIC
euh un SMIC un SMIC et demi avec un
enfant euh vous avez du mal à faire face
aux dépenses courantes d'après Pascal
Rodier sur les 7000 personnes qui
reçoivent une aide alimentaire la moitié
sont des enfants rappelons qu'en France
chaque année plus de de 2 millions et
demi de personnes sollicite
l'association et l' vient de l'apprendre
le chômage a légèrement reculé en France
en aû moins 6400 demandeurs d'emploi ce
sont les chiffres de Pôle Emploi qui ont
été diffusés ce soir l'insertion par la
culture le château de versaill vient de
signer un nouveau partenariat de 2 ans
avec l'pide comprenz établissement
public d'insertion de jeunes volontaires
éloignés de l'emploi vont pouvoir
s'intégrer socialement
professionnellement aussi en découvrant
notamment les métiers d'art yolen Torz
et William pour les
images pour la plupart il découvrent
Versailles pour la première fois eux ce
sont les jeunes volontaires de l'Épide
un établissement public d'insertion lors
d'un parcours de 8 à 24 mois en internat
ces jeunes âgés de 18 à 25 ans
travaillent à leur réinsertion sociale
et professionnelle ce jour-là ils
partent à la découverte des métiers
d'art et participent à un jeu de piste
dans les jardins du château c'est super
super intéressant parce que peu de gens
peuvent y aller peu de gens peuvent
avoir des organisations qui le organise
ça du coup et euh ça nous donne beaucoup
de beaucoup de connaissance en venant là
avec avec des gens qui nous expliquent
toutes les statutes toute l'histoire qui
peut y avoir autour de versaill c'est
important pour eux d'avoir une ouverture
d'esprit de connaître le patrimoine de
la France il est important d'associer
ces jeunes volontaires à l'insertion le
plus possible à ce genre d'activité ce
qui marque ce jour surtout c'est la
signature d'un partenariat de 2 ans
entre l'pide et le château de Versailles
un nouveau partenariat qui permettra aux
jeunes de participer aux activités du
château d'y effectuer un stage ou encore
un contrat de
professionnalisation ce partenariat a
cette particularité qu'il offre à la
fois la découverte sur les métiers d'art
qui sont pratiqués à Versailles à
l'exemple de ce que vous pouvez voir
aujourd'hui autour de nous sur les
jardins sur les fontaines sur les
doreurs les bronziers les fontainiers
les tableurs de plomb qui sont des
métiers assez rares actuellement en
France 18 établissements publics
d'insertion accueillent un peu plus de
2000 jeunes volontaires
une pause dans ce journal pour vous
montrer ces photos c'est sans doute
l'image du jour dans les Yvelines pour
les amateurs de basket le champion NBA
avec sint anonio Tony Parker était au
Technocentre Renault à Guill en cours
pour une démonstration partenaire de la
Marco losangees il est venu à la
rencontre des salariés nouvelle étape de
sa tournée française avant de repartir
aux États-Unis pour défendre son titre
avec les Spurs les fermes peuvent aussi
être un symbole du patrimoine culturel
français elles ont traversé les siècles
même ici dans les evelines où l'on parle
plus souvent de villes nouvelles exemple
à champgarnier une ancienne dépendance
des granges de Port Royal à manilamot
une visite qui était organisée dimanche
dernier toujours dans le cadre des
Journées du Patrimoine claire Cambier et
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud le cheval était quand même un des
bi précieux du fermier et donc l'écurie
est toujours à côté était dans la suite
alors as avec Jean-Paul Carcel on fait
un saut dans le temps pour imaginer
cette ferme au 17e siècle une visite
organisée dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine sur le thème des fermes
remarquables
c'est l'occasion de de venir aussi
découvrir ce patrimoine qui est à côté
de chez nous qu'on a b peu le loisir de
rencontrer le reste du temps ou le reste
de l'année et en plus là
d'avoir un accompagnement par un guide
qualifié pour qui qui nous donne des
clés pour comprendre aussi comment les
choses ont évolué et pourquoi elles ont
évolué car ces fermes font partie de
notre patrimoine ici pas de pièce de
musée mais des bâtiments qui datent du
17e au 21e siècle toujours en activité
Changarnier s'est adapté à la production
agricole moderne sans perdre de son
caché
l'étable qui normalement se trouvait
juste à côté de moi qu'on doit voir
derrière moi maintenant se trouve dans
la grange parce que on a installé des
systèmes automatiques d'évacuation des
du
fumier et qui va s'évacuer
automatiquement derrière la grange pour
éviter d'avoir le tas de fumier au
milieu de la cour comme c'était le cas
autre fois pour Didier des
l'exploitant c'est l'occasion de faire
découvrir son héritage familial une
bâtise acquise par son grand-père belge
en 1920 au passage il confie les dessous
de son métier l'élevage beauvin et la
culture céréalière et en fait la
température du grain est trop chaude
donc du coup ça se conserve moins bien
donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on descend
les
températures en bonus on y apprend même
une anecdote sur la porte des champs
cette ouverture à l'arrière de la grange
lorsque le Vallet de ferme voulait
quitter la ferme le soir sans se faire
repérer par par son patron hein il
voulait aller faire la fête au village
ou retrouver sa belle pour toutes ses
raisons et bien il s'éclipsait par la
porte des champs hein qui passait à
travers la campagne et pour se faire il
fallait qu'il prenne la clé des champs
d'où l'expression prendre la clé des
champs pour ceux qui souhaite une séance
de rattrapage il faudra attendre le mois
de juin changgarnier ouvre de nouveau
ses portes au public pour pour la fête
des
fermes culture Gérard Manoni depuis 60
ans c'est un sculpteur qui a marqué le
territoire de Saint-Quentin en niveline
avec notamment la fontaine Jacques brê à
Guill en cour il a aussi dessiné des
flacons de parfum encore des bijoux
exposition à découvrir actuellement au
musée de la ville Catherine zulato
William Gérard Manoni est sculpteur il
se présente comme un artiste non
figuratif qui aime prendre son temps je
suis un sculpteur qui travaille très
lentement je je remets oup souvent mes
œuvres je les reprends peu à
[Musique]
peu on trouve un
équilibre qui vous convient tant que cet
équilibre n pas n'est pas trouvé ben on
continue à travailler sur l'œuvre J'aime
bien souvent me rapprocher de des
problèmes des musiciens comment comment
un
musicien trouve l'inspiration pour
construire une symphonie Gérard Manoni
n'aime donc pas les fausses notes
musique son domaine de prédilection la
médecine aussi mon père était médecin et
je rapproch souvent ma ma profession de
du travail d'un médecin je me demande si
un artiste n pas un peu un peu pareil qu
il se trouve dans un dans un espace
qu'on lui demande d'animer il faut bien
qu'il trouve quelque chose
qui qui soit pas malade qui tiennent
debout Gérard Manoni a travaillé
plusieurs matières la pierre et le
plâtre à ses débuts puis le bois le
métal l'acier l'aluminium son
attachement à 50 ans nieline est
particulier ces 20 ans de ma vie de
sculpteur explique-t-il en sourient dans
les années 70 il travaille en effet
conjointement avec l'architecte de la
gare de 50 ans en Yveline pour produire
un escalier extérieur mais le projet
n'aboutit pas 20 ans plus tard Gérard
Manoni revient à guilloncour pour y
réaliser la place à Jacques Bren c'était
quand même le travail le plus le plus
compx que j'ai fait de tous les tous les
travaux dans
ond moi j'appartiens un peu à
cel au musée de la ville une
cinquantaine d'œuvres est exposé
également les croquis très détaillé de
gerérard Manoni jusqu'au boulon qu'il
dessine lui-même une précision que l'on
retrouve aussi dans cette travaux pour
Pierre Cardin qu'est-ce que vous
aimeriez qu'on qu'on dise de vos uvres
c'est du travail sérieux voilà
actuellement faire une sculpture c'est à
la portée de tout le monde enfin les
enfants les vieux tout le monde et et
tout s'il y a pas vraiment une
profondeur de pensée s'il y a pas un
sérieux je crois que c'est pas la peine
de faire de la
sculpture je vous redonne cette
information si vous n'étiez pas avec
nous au début de cette édition attrape
un homme de 26 ans a été blessé par bal
hier soir mardi il se trouve à l'hôpital
privé de la commune avec une plie à
l'abdomen son pronostic vital n'est pas
engagé la conséquence d'un affrontement
qui a éclaté un peu plus tôt aux
alentours de 18h dans un quartier de la
ville le soir les grange théâtre de
violence entre une quarantaine de jeunes
la police est intervenue pour les
disperser avant de retrouver sur place
barre de fer couteau ou encore bomb
laacrymogène une enquête est en cours
pour homicide volontaire et puis nous
terminons avec une pensée émue pour un
homme Antoine farougia fondateur
entraîneur emblématique du Boxing Club
de saintquenttins en Yveline à hencour
est décédé à 68 ans il aura mené une
carrière amateur avant de travailler
avec les plus grands entraîneurs manager
et promoteur de la profession plusieurs
de ces boxeurs ont connu le succès grâce
à lui en France et sur les rings
européen le club a posté aujourd'hui un
dernier message hommage sur les réseaux
sociaux tu as livré ton dernier round on
continue le combat debout làhaut prend
soin de ton équipe ta famille et tes
enfants merci de nous avoir suivi votre
soirée sur tvfils et notamment avec
Catherine zulato pour kiosque le
magazine de la culture cette semaine il
est question du Festival de la bande
dessinée à Buc très bonne
soirée